Markiplier: Baaaam ba la nam bam bam baaaaaam!
It's... BOB!
Hi Bob, I'm gonna be coming over to you!
I'm gonna hop on a plane and then go over here
and then probably here
maybe here
a little bit of here
[Radio noises repeating 'Mayday']
summoning under here
venturing...
OH GOD! WHAT IS THAT!? AHHHHHH-
And then I'm gonna land and visit you at your own home
because we're gonna be doing a charity livestream together for MusAid!
And if you don't know about MusAid
which you probably should considering you told me,
BOB!
It's a charity that supports musical institutions in developing countries
It's great!
So I'm gonna bring my guitar,
and I'm gonna bring my trumPET
and we're gonna have ourselves a duo!
(Immitating trumpet) Beep Beep Beep
Heaa I got an actual trumpet here...
(Trumpet) Doot... Doot
Hang on!
(Trumpet) Doot
Haa
(Trumpet) Boop
Almost got it!
(Trumpet) Boopadoop
Fu... Uhh, hang on
(Trumpet) Doot!
Ah fuck...
So all you people out there watching, please join us this Saturday
for a charity livestream of epic proportions
And you know what they say!
"M-Markiplier doesn't know how to end a video!.."
(Awkward silence while music is still playing)
We're gonna JAM out with our cocks-
Err what?